Well, Democrats may have an intention of resisting
Donald Trump on a lot of issues in his first
100 days and in the first two years of his
administration.
They don't have the votes to effectively stop
him, at least not in the House of Representatives
where they're at one of the low points they've
had since 1928.
They have enough votes in the Senate to sustain
a filibuster, but as the outgoing Democratic
leader, Harry Reid, pointed out, he changed
the filibuster rules for lower federal court
nominations, and there's nothing to stop the
Republican majority from changing them for
Supreme Court nominations, which one will
be on tap, or on other issues.
I think an interesting point is whether or
not the Republicans can move ahead on immigration
and can peel off some Democratic votes here.
And also on infrastructure issues.
The Democrats say they want to build more
infrastructures, so does the president-elect.
Will some of them go along with a package
that he will put in that might get away with
certain obstructions?
We'll see.